c'est Mario Bella Jamison ma Nana
et c'est ma visite pop-pop pour la
semaine Je voulais passer du temps avec toi depuis
si longtemps ouais je ne t'ai jamais vu aussi
heureux depuis des années qu'il est
9h30
vous deux devriez  je ne sors pas de ta chambre
à gauche bonne nuit qu'est-
ce que c'était que
je pense que Nana ne se sent pas bien
grand-mère va bien alors et papa
accouche des souches je savais que nous allions
avoir son appel ce sont juste des gens bizarres
hé les garçons  unité anistar seule
et il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas avec Nana
et pop-pop donc juste vieux juste nettoyer ici
ce qui est dans le hangar ici cela vous
dérangerait-il d'entrer dans le four pour le nettoyer